Netflix developer story for Android
We have seen significant growth in emerging markets
Many of these markets rely on mobile users
Some of these users enter the Internet for the first time using their phones
The phones they use most of the time rely on Android
Improving the performance of our Android app is critical to us
Because we look forward to offering a great experience for those markets
Application size is an important component of Netflix
Because it directly affects the installation rate
When Google announced the dynamic application and delivery package
We were very happy
This has given us many potentials to benefit from and to improve our application
By improving the size of our application
Go to use the application package and dynamic features
We must first identify the elements we want to modify
Take into consideration any large component and restrict usage
Such as language and translation
And we turned around one of the features we offer
They communicate with customer support service, to dynamic advantage
So if the user really needs this feature
Will go to the Help section
This feature will be downloaded to this user
Go to the application package and the dynamic features
Enables us to reduce application download by 33%
Where application size decreased from 23 MB to 15 MB
We have a few other features we are working to turn into dynamic features
We expect an additional volume reduction in the coming months